why would a writer stop
writing writer would stop writing when
they have nothing else to say
maybe you know or they would stop
writing because they haven't achieved
a level where they thought they would be
maybe i'm giving up you know i'm not i
didn't sell an a-list script
i'm gonna go sell carpets you know
carpet cleaning something whatever job
it is
um you would hope that a writer would
you know would stay in the game and just
because
we got you know like officer and
gentleman i've got nowhere else to go
you know i got nothing else i want to do
you know i i
i need to tell stories
i'm a storyteller you know and
it's tragic when you hear people writers
you know give up and i understand
because
everybody has their limits and they you
know it's like
it's uh and you know it could be not
giving up
let's say pursuing it full-time but
maybe dabbling on the side and then that
takes longer and sure life can get in
the way and then
you know it's it it falls along the
wayside and maybe wasn't
as interesting of a pursuit as the
writer thought it was
you know and because it went up against
that test
you know the difficulty test and
you know that's always like i say how
badly do you want it rejection criticism
failure that's usually the litmus test
of how bad you want to be in this you
know because
we're all going to experience in that
even after you make it you start working
you're gonna be fired you know and stuff
um
so yeah they're all fear
too maybe i'll never you know achieve
what i
thought i would you know but i say the
longer you're in it that kind of changes
too
just by its nature of being in this you
know at least for me
how you look at things you know so it
could be a number of reasons why someone
quits
you know but i always it's always a sad
day for me to hear that going ah one of
her
you know brethren her sisters stopped
you know they you know maybe it would
just be around that next corner
you know maybe it's that next script but
that's also the
chasing the dragon you know like well
not this one and we all have to
maybe it's the next one maybe it's the
one after that and then
you know what i mean so everybody has to
have their own
uh self-reflection about you know how
long you're going to give this
you know i like i say i never put an
expiration date on my screenwriting
dream so i didn't say but by this date i
have to
you know and thank goodness stuff worked
out a bit you know
but i don't know if i was doing it for
10 15 years and
there was no forward movement what i
would think about it you know
so i think it's a personal thing
everyone has to every writer has to ask
themselves
so when you started writing you had one
mindset
for it and now you've gone into
something that's just maybe a little
more relaxed or
okay realistic okay yeah not relaxed
about the work by the way but just
know about about certain goals and and
in terms of yeah sure it has to be
you know i have to be here by this point
kind of thing yeah
or what you want to do don't you want to
direct it's like
you know i'd rather produce and write
you know directing
there's a lot of directors you know and
having done it in film school yeah but i
have no project to show someone it's
like oh you're
you're the one over this person in fact
i would probably
um on a project step aside and let
a director who i would pick direct the
movie that's more of a producer's
thing you know um
so i don't know it changes you know out
of film school
i kind of always wanted to be a writer
but then the longer you're in the
business you go hmm
writers get kicked around a lot stuff
gets changed a lot and you're always at
the mercy of someone else
hiring you but if you're a producer
writer
or you move into producing where you say
this is my project
you don't get it i'm going to put the
elements together you know and i know
i'm a producer
you know type of thing so things can
change
since our last interview which was 2017
i believe around
the holidays yeah 2017 have you
changed your mind about any of the
writing process
maybe you were in one camp where you
said
i'm not going to do it this way or i
only do it this way and then now
several years later you've changed where
you've loosened up on that
or you've completely anything about the
writing process
that has changed for you where you were
very dogmatic about something and then
um i don't know i think the dog was
still there
but i think the process of being
i wanted to get back to more like i can
remember the days when ideas would just
pop up you know and this and that
and uh i would find an idea that i would
be so passionate about that i would see
it ah
you know and you know when you're
working on assignments it's kind of
different
i mean you have to do that but it's
it's you know i i like uh
what i'm trying to say is i want to get
back into more of that
spec stuff for me cells are not whatever
you know i've got um other spec ideas
that i
have are pretty decent shape they've
been you know i pitched them and they've
been around and stuff but
um to maybe take one and and expand it
into something else instead of a tv
pilot make it a feature or maybe write a
book of it you know type of thing so
i'm one thing i would say is i'm opening
my mind more to different
creative possibilities than just the
straight and narrow type
um so yeah in that way
but the way that the way that um
i work no you know i'm open to
suggestion but so far you know it seems
to work
you know for what i'm doing so
yeah but i'm always open to you know
you always have to be you know like
water flows you know so it's like
is that part of the tai chi you think
either the tai chi
changed that or you already changed and
then you wanted to do the tai chi
because it's kind of about the flow of
energy
yeah i think that's going to help me
more on
this next plateau you know in
in in studying the certain philosophies
to try to um
uh you know have them dictate toward
writing
in a way you know trying to make them
sort of similar or it's life you know i
mean
these kind of philosophies are for life
too as well you know
discipline right you know patience
things like that
and with tai chi it's not if you hit
back it's you
shift your energy yeah it's it's it
you're always
you're always it's a flow you know what
i mean so it's um
trying to flow through life that's what
i'm trying to do
and uh you know when you come up against
these hurdles with screenwriting
um not to take them as the end-all
be-all
your life's over type of thing you know
and i say that for beginning riders as
well
you know especially because you're gonna
hit a lot of knocks that you could
want to give up you're going to say well
i'm not i'm not selling anything and
nobody's reading my stuff or how do i
get to do that and
you find a way you find you find that
one move that works you know
but yeah i saw a documentary uh
came out i think 2019 about miles
davis's career
and he reinvented himself so many times
yes
and there were times when he wanted to
give up or sure different things happen
with his health
but yeah he was always kind of
reinventing himself because you have you
know he spends so much time
that he you can't keep doing the stuff
back
you know you were doing in the 60s you
know you have to evolve in
and change you know and so um yeah i
believe in that too you have to
as you grow as a person you know
so too you have to grow as a
screenwriter you know what i mean
and it's storytelling so
right so he would infuse different
things i think he did like sort of he
had a
more latin percussion phase that he
put into his music and different things
with different costumes different looks
and it really helps keep this career
going and it keeps you fresh that's the
key
you know and you don't look at it as
like
this thing you know that i have to do
you come back to it from that 11 year
old kid that was like oh this thing that
i love to do that i'm blessed to do
that i'm blessed to get paid to do you
know i was blessed to do it anyway but
get paid is even better
you know because so yeah
you